Now for the formal definition
of a polynomial reduction.
This should feel very similar to the
reductions that we considered when we
were talking about computability.
A language, A, is polynomial reducible
to a language, B, and we write this as
A less than or equal to B with
the subscript P over the less than or
equal to sign, if there is
a polynomial function, f where for
every string w, w is in A, if and
only if f(w) is in the language B.
The key difference from before is that
we have now required that the function
be computable in polynomial time,
not just that it be computable.
We will also say that f is
a polynomial time reduction of A to B,
or sometimes from A to B.
Here's the key implication of
there being a polynomial reduction
of one language to another.
Let's suppose that I want to know
whether a string x is in the language A.
And suppose,
also, that there exists a polynomial
decider, M for the language, B.
Then all I need to do
is take the machine or
program that computes
this reduction function.
Let's call it N.
And feed my string x into it.
And then feed that output into M.
M will tell if f(x) is in B.
But by definition of a reduction,
this also tells whether x is in A,
which is exactly what I wanted to know.
I just had to change my problem into
one encoded by the language B and
then I could use B as decider.
By the way,
this square bracket notation means 1
if the expression inside is true,
and 0 otherwise.
Therefore, the composition
of M with N is a decider for
A, by all the same arguments we used
in the context of computability.
But is it a polynomial decider?